I'm down here in the Florida Everglades
with Python hunter professional Python
hunter Mike and we are going to try to
catch cook eat a Burmese python
[Music]
now what these are these are Burmese
pythons these are people's pets that
some yo hos let loose into the swamp
thinking they were giving their pets a
better life and now these things have
established a breeding population here
in Southwest Florida they're just
causing havoc they eat all sorts of
endangered species they compete with
native species and their populations are
exploding but the government has
commissioned certain bounty hunters so
to speak without 25 ive hunters that are
allowed to go on government property and
hunt for these things and they get paid
a bounty these professional snake
hunters like Mike are going around
trying their best to try to put a check
on these Burmese snake these Burmese
pythons what's the average size of
average size over six now when we see
one is it the kind of thing where we
just bail out of this card run as fast
as we can
and as soon as you get your hands on it
and headed to go time it's gonna freak
out freak out alright the sun's starting
to get low so we're putting on our
floodlights here we're just scanning
scanning and scanning for a big fat six
foot plus snake this is pretty awesome
being out here at night you're getting
to see a part of the Everglades that
people normally don't get to see and
it's just I'm on pins and needles you
know it's a wintertime we may not see
any pythons or we might see a bunch we
just don't know what you see you oh my
goodness I'd to know what that is so
here's a here's a Python slide through
here and the reason I know it's a Python
not in alligators because there's no
foot tracks on the side so that's all
Python oh yeah right there
look at that big just sliding right
through the mud oh that's so cool I'm so
excited this is gonna be awesome
Brown water snakes so apparently that's
a good sign because where you see one
type of snake you often see the others
so we're starting to see more snakes
that's good now hopefully we'll go see a
big Daddy snake look at that nice little
door in there spots on him he's gorgeous
I think that's a tilapia poor bike man
he can't go any duty snake hunting
because I want to look at every little
bugging critter just nerding me out this
is all these cool species this is fun in
his home
here at all
[Music]
did those yeah look at that
check this out guys there was this
little alligator sitting in the road
poor little guys missing two hind legs
and he got a little bone sticking out
been in his front right shoulder and a
little bit of his tail man he's having a
rough day
well rough life oh man
oh yeah we're just gonna go ahead and
put him in the ditch here
another champion good luck stumpy I'm
going along this ditch and I'm seeing
gar and tilapia and bass and oh there's
a big old Oscar right there that's a big
one
oh there's the snake
all right native snake so Mike just told
me that that when a Python are born
they're bigger than that water snake we
just saw that's that's a big freaking
baby we're seeing so much cool stuff out
here check it out there's a big old
alligator look at that I just poked his
head up got someone up ahead here let's
see who this is got some fellow Python
hunters here set up here I've got the
camping chair on the roof
LED lights all around sit up there with
the spotlight I like it all right Mike's
gonna train me up a little bit you know
how when you get a new bird dog you
gotta you gotta give them a doc to train
on Mike's gonna pull out a Python here
for me to to see and film a little bit
you to help me help me get the feel of
it this is about a 1 year old Python
yeah maybe even a little bit younger
oh look at that
they pretty aggressive or they like the
bite thing yeah you know this one you
can see it's shedding this I hear they
get touchy Saints get touchy when
there's weather [ __ ] yeah definitely
this is a wild animal this is not a pet
this is a it's hard to tell at this age
but this man knows the snake privates
how do you just try to bite my knee yeah
yeah so what you're gonna want to do is
yeah try not to piss it off and fling it
around try to keep it keep it calm I'll
kind of distract it a little bit and
you're gonna want to confidently and do
not hesitate do it don't do it
yeah go right for it and right now it's
a perfect time right behind his head
scoop it right up that beautiful nicely
done like a pro you know buddy alright
so we're going to put the middle of the
snake in first
yeah there's a little bit of snakeskin
but a little bit more and give me some
cowboy boots that was way fun I've
wanted to do that for a while we're
about five hours and many miles into
this Python hunt we've seen a lot of
cool stuff but no pythons yet so we've
moved spots we're going to try a little
something different we're just gonna
cruise around here and maybe just maybe
we're gonna pull out a big ol fat
Burmese python
alright go ahead and grab its tail now
and yeah grab its hail and hold on do
not let go nice job now it this sneaks
kind of cooled down this is good it's
gonna make it a little bit easier slowly
work your way up towards towards its
head kind of wait for it wait for a
chance to to get it when it's kind of
stopped and calm down yep
now's your chance beautiful like a pro
nicely done
very nice yeah buddy yeah good deal man
oh that is so awesome there it is
Everglades Python how was that that was
every bit as awesome as those teeth
you'd see what you mean about them you
jacking you up it's got two rows
very much nicely done brother
okay guys it's 112 in the morning we've
been doing this since about 5:00 and you
know I've been just staring at grass for
hours and looking in ditches for hours
and and then finally like quick sneak 8
foot Python just stretched out a couple
feet on the side of the road blew my
mind yeah whoo yeah I'm not sleepy now
oh yeah right there this is so cool I've
seen more different species of snakes in
the wild on this night that I have my
whole life combined I want to see a big
old Python in these lily pads just so I
can see Mike jump on in after it all
right we got an alligator here at the
bottom of the levee and
[Music]
almost 4 a.m. has been a long day
there's been an awesome day best day
sure much coming out at a great time
you've got to follow Mike on Instagram
he's got he's got an amazing Instagram
page on there so I'm gonna put a link in
the description bar is the catch and
cook part of this video
Oh what happens with these snakes is
he's got to take him to a biologist
between Monday through Friday at certain
times and it's Saturday morning right
now and I'm gonna be leaving Florida
before Monday so what he's gonna do is
he's gonna go ahead take it to the
biologists they're gonna return the meat
back to him he's gonna ship it to me in
Virginia and then we're gonna do the
second half of this video where we cook
up the Python behind the snakes here
well I'm really anxious to see what this
looks like guys hey check it out all
right guys this is not the snake I
caught with Mike
apparently that snake that the meats
still with the biologist or something
like that and I've got a trip to Spain
planned for tomorrow so I called up my
Clinton he can you give me that meat
ASAP I kind of need to I kind of need to
wrap up this video and so he's it no
problem buddy and he sent me this
hatchling so apparently this massive
snake here this bag is just a baby
Python it's a little hatch Lee and there
appears to be several heads in here I'm
not sure this might be the head of my
snake I don't know but I got a bonus
pack I'm gonna go ahead and make
deep-fried Python nuggets because if
I've learned anything from eating weird
stuff
if in doubt deep-fry it so we're gonna
get going with that got a big thing of
peanut oil which I keep around just for
such occasions we're going to get it
heated up got all-purpose flour some
beaten up eggs and some panko
breadcrumbs here and I also have some
Creole seasoning but you know salt and
pepper
old bay Everglade whatever you like that
also works to see what we got oh yeah
oh it's still got the head attached well
least we know which one belongs to them
then there's a bonus head and oh look
another bonus head oh yeah what did that
it's that's not gutted I'm gonna take a
gander here just cut through the spine
but not the esophagus and then I should
let me pull the esophagus and all the
stuff is attached to it out I don't know
anything about gutting snakes but I do
hold firmly to the principle that
anything you don't want to put in your
mouth you take out look at that oh
that's that was easy
that looks like meat a little bit of
brown stuff right around here
maybe the guts broke or something so I
might cut that out just to be safe I
don't know if that's bile or what all
right there we go that looks pretty
decent
well looking at a cross-section of this
little baby Python here it looks like
the bones are on this side pretty
shallow and this is all just meat right
here on the back strap so I think if I
had a big snake I would just run right
down the back and get two back straps
off the whole length of the snake and be
done with it
no bone all right so before we get
started we're going to season the meat
with Creole seasoning all right this is
real simple we take a piece of snake we
roll it in the all-purpose flour and get
the whole thing thoroughly coated in
flour then you go and you shake off any
excess and then you drop it in the egg
shake off any excess egg then drop it in
the poncho and then roll it around and
get it thoroughly coated in the
breadcrumb you don't want to use bread
crumbs you can use a cornmeal or
crumbled up Ritz crackers it all works
really well
oh that has a snaky smell to it
well that's oils a little hot let's take
that off and my oil is a touch hot
that's a little bit black yeah I think I
burned those what do you think that oil
is way too hot
oh well well I was debating whether to
do blackened Python or Python Nuggets
and I decided to do both so we have like
it's but we could just kind of like pick
the breading off and give it a go down
bad yeah I think we need a dipping sauce
of sorts well what would you put Python
in sauce chick-fil-a sauce right let's
do it
now I have made image of a cow on a
billboard saying eat more Python I am a
little nervous about it more or less
nervous than the squirrel it's a toss-up
I'm gonna dive into a bigger piece like
the moment the whole thing is like a
ribcage they just take the breading off
that was we'll just admit that was a
failure and just take that all off kind
of springy yeah kind of springy and
you're sure it's good it's kind of like
string cheese you know I love you right
oh you love you so much I'm not that
excited Python look because you haven't
tasted it yet the chick-fil-a sauce
tastes just like chicken mm-hmm it's
like meaty string cheese it's kind of a
rubbery meat and it's kind of stringy
you know it'd just be like peeled pieces
off the back this is like eating a piece
of Street cheese made of snake I mean
it's not bad but it's definitely a
rubbery meat texture is weird I wonder
if that's true for the big pythons yeah
I don't know what's more I'm shucking a
Python that's the technical term for
taking the meat off of Python is
shucking
peels off like that a lot of tendons in
there it's a very rubbery piece of meat
it's not as rubbery as octopus but it
kind of reminds me of it yeah like
chicken and octopus had a baby
not my favorite media ever but it
doesn't taste bad it's just the textures
rubbery
well everyone thank you for watching we
hope you enjoyed this Python Captain
Cook definitely check out some of our
other videos including our squirrel
catch and cook video we did recently and
we've got a lots of other videos they
have nothing to do with catching more
cooking and don't forget to click
subscribe to the outdoor boys youtube
channel thanks for watching if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]